what joining me now is the former
Arizona governor nominee and Rising Star
the Republican Party Carrie Lake who
remained a big supporter of the former
president she's outside the court there
in Miami uh carry him in extraordinary
scenes they're obviously unprecedented
we've never had any current or uh
ex-president of the United States
indicted on federal charges and most
people I've I've spoken to uh I'm just
hearing by the way breaking news Donald
Trump has pled not guilty to these
charges but most people I've spoken to
from a legal point of view describe
these charges as indeed Jane wildtrap
just did as exceptionally serious and
certainly way more serious than the
charges relating to Stormy Daniels and
hush money payments so what is your
response having read the indictment
well you're right we've never seen this
happen before because we've never had
someone as corrupt as Joe Biden sitting
in the White House turning our
government against our people we've
never had someone like Joe Biden who is
in fact a criminal himself who's taken
bribes from the CCP who's taken bribes
from Ukraine and many others having to
turn and weaponize our department to go
after his rival and this is election
interference Donald Trump is an innocent
man he will be found innocent at the end
of the day and the American people are
fed up they're tired of watching our
government being weaponized against us
and this is outrageous there was a
beautiful show of support for president
Trump there were many people showing
that President Trump waving the
president Trump flags and it was really
a nice setup down there where a lot of
people came out to say we're tired of
this and we're tired of our government
being turned against us I mean the
problem I have with that Gary I've read
the indictment closely and apart from
anything else you hear him on tape
Donald Trump clearly conceding the
documents he has have not been
Declassified something he always said
he'd done uh which many lawyers say is
just a fate accompli right there that
he's admitting himself that these are
not Declassified documents and he's
sharing the details with other people
I sure wish they would share with these
documents are they're being very mum
about what's in them I'm really curious
about what's in them and Pierce there's
more evidence of wrongdoing and crime
frankly in uh on Hillary Clinton servers
there's more evidence of crime in Joe
Biden's garage and those boxes where he
had no ability to declassify those
documents because he was a Senator and a
vice president and frankly there's more
evidence of a crime on Monica Lewinsky's
dress than in those boxes that were
pulled from Mar-A-Lago and everybody
knows it everybody's tired of this
charade
his administration is is is illegitimate
as well okay how do you know that Carrie
how can you be so sure a what's in the
documents and how do you explain that
even when he was asked to give the stuff
back he didn't
you know what the president has the
right to take the items from the White
House it's happened with Obama it's
happened with previous presidents it's
happened with Bill Clinton they have the
right to do that and presidents have the
right to declassify documents they don't
even have to announce that they can just
think about it and they can be
Declassified it doesn't matter this is a
bogus case and you know what it is it's
really just a way Pierce to give cover
to Joe Biden who just this week we found
out took another 5 million dollar bribe
and payout from the CCP and we have 17
recordings of him according to Senator
Grassley on tape being recorded taking
bribes and payouts from Ukraine this is
a distraction to give you in the media
something to talk about so you don't
have to talk about the crimes Joe Biden
commits
for the next five years I have no truck
I have no truck in defending Joe Biden
from anything or Hillary Clinton I was
savagely critical of Hillary Clinton
throughout the whole email Scandal I
thought that was outrageous ages and I
do think there are legitimate charges of
double standards here particularly from
the liberal skewed U.S mainstream media
about the way they've treated Hillary
Clinton's emails Joe Biden's documents
and others I think it's a completely
valid point but that doesn't in itself
negate the severity of what Donald Trump
is accused of doing here so my question
to you is if he's actually convicted
hang on Gary if he's convicted is it
really realistic that Donald Trump as a
convicted felon on serious federal
charges would continue to run for
president or indeed win the White House
which he couldn't be in
Pierce you haven't you haven't been in
the states um recently to find out just
how corrupt our government from top to
bottom this government is corrupt the
judicial branch the doj the CDC the FBI
this entire Administration is corrupt
and Donald Trump is an innocent man we
know that this is just another which no
you believe it
but we don't know that ever since we got
it this has been one thing to give you
guys something to talk about stop
talking about you guys like we're all
the same I don't have anything in common
with a lot of the media that you have
this big problem with but what I would
say about this is I read the indictment
these are serious charges and I don't
think that the special counsel who's
leveled them could be deemed to be a
partisan guy so there's a possibility
Trump gets convicted so my question
again if he is convicted should he or
could he run for office
you can indict a ham sandwich conviction
is a whole other story and he should run
for office he's not going to quit Donald
Trump is the only person standing up for
We the People our government has turned
on us right now we have an illegitimate
Joe Biden sitting in office weaponizing
our government against his lead rival
this is election interference they know
they can't stop president Trump they
know he has the people behind him they
know he's going to win and they keep
trying to throw these other candidates
in trying to get the American people
excited about these other people and
they're not they want president Trump in
office and the only way to stop him is
to throw bogus indictments at him and
try to arrest him and stop him okay
this is not going away you you believe
they're all bogus and you have a
touching loyalty to Donald Trump I want
to play a clip this is from you I
believe on Friday talking about what may
happen
if you want to get to president
25 million Americans just like me and
I'm going to tell you yep
most of us are card carrying members of
the NRA
foreign
that's not a threat
that's a public service announcement we
will not let you lay a finger on
President Trump
frankly now is the time frankly now is
the time to cling to our guns and our
religion thank you Georgia
that's pretty incendiary stuff Carrie to
suggest that you've all got your guns
and you're going to use them to defend
Donald Trump
that's not what I said I am using my
freedom of speech to say that we support
president Trump Millions hundreds of
millions of Americans do and the
law-abiding gun owners in America are
not the trouble it's the outrageous
rioters on the street that you know the
media has supported Don Lemon defending
antifa calling it peaceful protests we
know what you know you guys you guys
will always defend
it's saying you guys what do you mean
you guys
you think I've got anything in common
with Don Lemon really have you watched
my show
actually did Don Lemon ever have you on
his show like I have I I see I see how
you constantly attack Trump and I know
that that's what your network wants
because that's their name is nothing to
do with the name that I work for and by
the way I have regularly supported Trump
on his warranted support and I have
regularly criticized him when I felt he
deserves criticism now I'm taking it
yeah I'm taking a more down the line
position which is he has been indicted
with very serious charges you may not
like it but you don't know that he's
innocent you just hope he is
Pierce this this whole government is
illegitimate right now under Joe Biden
it's completely gone Bonkers and they're
they are they're weaponizing our
department of justice it should be
called the department of Injustice right
now against Trump when the real criminal
is sitting in the white house right now
he doesn't even know where he is his
name is Joe Biden he has taken tens of
millions of dollars of bribes and
they're trying to deflect and put the
attention on Trump to give you in the
media somebody to talk about and
something negative to say about Trump
has been for eight years just for the
record I haven't mentioned Biden other
than when I've responded to you so when
you say you the media
is that me saying you politicians as if
you're all the same you're not so stop
calling me you the media anyway I've got
to leave it there but it's always a joy
to catch up with you you do work for one
of the big you you work for one of the
corporate Giants you work for Rupert
Murdoch and I understand he is for
making sure Trump doesn't get into
office and you know that's who signs
your check Pierce so you got to go alone
is anti-trump I have had absolutely no
instruction from anybody of fox to have
any opinion about anybody that's just
not what happens there you might think
it does nobody has ever said to me I
know what I should say about Donald
Trump it's worse than you think I say
things I actually mean I'm one of those
guys in the media I've worked in the
media for 30 years under one of these
corporate Giants I won't name who and so
I understand this subtle pressure you
get all right
let's leave it there not because I'm
cutting you off but because you've had
more time than we allocated I've got to
get into all the news and other things I
always love interviewing having you on
the show it's always robust but just for
the record nobody tells me what to think
you'll say and that's why it's called
uncensored Carrick great to talk to you
same here God bless you